moi je suis hyper bien faire Renault qui
chante maître Gims
aussi Marc-Olivier Fogiel qui chante
fous ta cagoule
là fous ta cagoule
tu auras les boules
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu sais faire toi moi je
sais faire à part le pigeon avec ta meuf
[Applaudissements]
il est magnifique lève-toi lève-toi va
bien dit merde
quand tu seras dans le prêt-à-porter tu
crois en fait non tu es beau comme ça
merci tu as passé un bon weekend toi je
le sens super weekend Fatou Fatou ma
fille des petites promenades un petit
peu de gastronomie tout est nickel
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez mais alors maintenant il
y a des gars qui imitent mettre des
bisous
non non non non non
toi timide qui toi moi alors je fais un
crossover entre Pierre Perret et Mylène
Farmer
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas pour ça Patrick parce qu'on a
je dois aller faire pipi toutes les 10
minutes vas-y
moi c'est un duo avec vous c'est j'ai
encore rêvé d'elle vous faites le garçon
je fais la fille mais c'est mais laissez
pas se faire les autres d'abord
en fait
non parce que Mathieu et moi on a envie
de savoir ton coming out c'est quand
même
noté parce que maman ça commence à faire
beaucoup bien sûr c'est génial je fais
la fille pour tous les routiers qui nous
regardent vas-y à outois
alors moi j'ai bossé tout le weekend
elle va nous sortir un autre Guillaume
bonsoir
c'est Béatrice
[Rires]
j'espère que tu vas bien je suis très
contente
très gentil une amie
là c'est plus c'est plus Eva longora là
spécialiste de la dératisation
je l'adore oui
[Rires]
s'il vous plaît
vous foutez de ma gueule on raconte de
ce que vous dites
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour l'instant c'est la meilleure
manière
ça c'est possible c'est possible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est ça ton vrai grand-père non
c'est vrai et donc il a beaucoup vu quoi
et donc ouais
des grandeurs non non mais la folie des
grands-mères ils connaissent pas c'est
Yves Montand voilà euh
chanteur grand artiste et c'est en plus
le grand-père de Benjamin Castaldi
personne n'est parfait non mais attends
[Rires]
pas du tout il y a pas d'héritage de ton
grand-père il y a des enfants avant mais
oui
je comprends plus rien à sa famille lui
c'est le seul famille son fils est plus
vieux que son nom
n'importe quoi la famille Castaldi frère
t'as des gars de 6 ans ils sont plus
vieux dégâts de 26 ans non mais tu es un
gars de 6 ans c'est l'oncle d'un gars de
35 ans
35 ans qui arrive chez son oncle salut
c'est un truc de fou ta famille on
comprend rien comprendre mais tu as
raison partout frère
il ne passe sur aucune aucune radio
c'est jamais quand est-ce que tu écoutes
entendues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est au pressing papa est au pressing
attends 10 minutes il va t'appeler
depuis 10 ans
elle est jolie la meuf du pressing ou
pas et vous nous faites un beau cadeau à
votre papa bien sûr c'est quoi
un bateau de 35 mètres un bateau
non une ville une ville
tu vas faire son point en pistache
il est hyper content il est hyper
content
salut les loups
The Voice les enfants
[Rires]
je suis venu vite fait quoi
deux minutes moi j'ai des gars qui
arrivent au bar là
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai fait des classiques donc là
je fais un
inéditrice dans le film que personne n'a
vu sur une page wikipédia oui c'était
qu'est-ce que c'est un bâtard
[Applaudissements]
la salle Vincent le savoir c'est rien
que ces actrices c'est sur ma page
silence
américaine traduit en français
alors tu es con parce que c'est c'est je
l'adore
tu veux pas faire ton voisin quelqu'un
qu'on connait bah Béatrice
alors tu l'as fait avec un autre texte
vas-y ah bah non mais c'est moi
je peux faire quelqu'un d'autre vas-y
encore une fiche je suis assez fort pour
moi c'est pas important la politique et
je considère que les gens aujourd'hui
veulent plus pleurer ils veulent rire et
moi je suis actuellement végétarienne
[Applaudissements]
je ne veux que personne ne rigole
tu sors pour très longtemps
et une fois j'ai donné à mon chien je me
non mais ta gueule
il me dégoûte ce mec c'est une horreur
excusez-le c'est un hommage
[Applaudissements]
oui Béatrice oui ça va bien
émission ben non non en direct
on t'entend là et à Mathieu qui
t'embrasse d'ailleurs
raté et que sans toi il est rien
[Applaudissements]
on était parti sur une séquence
d'imitation et là ça parle vraiment mais
oui je sais pas ce qu'il a eu lui un
rideau je crois la semaine prochaine